I actually want to start with your own
personal experience you've you've been
looked after by your grandparents
obviously you looked after your mother
yourself and you must have had to have
that kind of network of support around
you
what are the pressures on those people
who are trying to look after you and
raise you
well after my mum died when I was 15 my
nan and Grandad were critical to looking
after me and on most of the time I live
with them sometimes I live with my
brother but having that family to look
after you was was essential I was quite
lucky it was a loving family but you've
got to remember the trauma that my
grandparents were going through they'd
lost their only child my mother uh and
so they were hurting hard
um but they knew that their
responsibility what they wanted to do
was to look after their grandson yeah um
and so it was it was tough for them but
um in a way because it was a loving
family it worked yeah for a lot of
families you know if they've come from
disruptive backgrounds or and the child
is obviously going through trauma as
well in all of these cases uh it's it's
more difficult so where do you think the
support needs to be to keep those
children in those loving well I'm firm
believer that kinship carer grandparents
uncles aunts brother sisters they make
the best carers because they love the
the child the young person that's my
experience
and my liberal Democratic colleague Nira
Wilson has come up with a piece of
legislation which would really help
kinship carers play the role that they
want to play and that they're best to
play what do you think about you know
the government is has come out with this
response to the McAllister review they
are saying they're going to put support
in place to help with training and
things like that where do you think it
falls short
well I welcome that they've made a
report and there are some things there
that I welcome but it really is nowhere
near ambitious enough and nobody answers
the problem that many of our young
people are are facing in care when they
lose their loved ones or their loved
ones their mother and father are unable
to look after them so I really think
they need to get behind manira Wilson my
liberal Democratic colleagues idea of
funding a kinship care allowance on the
way that we fund the foster care
allowance I really think they need to be
far more supportive of kinship carers
and I'm afraid this report doesn't
doesn't anywhere doesn't touch the sides
how involved were your grandparents in
your upbringing
well they've been involved quite a lot
even my mother was alive because we'd
lost my father and my mother was only
child so we're very she was very close
to her parents and so we will often stay
with my uh grandparents
um that's my
Nana and Granddad
how old were you when how old were they
rather when you say you were 15 Nana was
about 65 when my mum died right and
coranda was about 66 because he died
when he was about 68.
and that must have hit them hard because
no one wants to see their own child go
before them that's the difficulty moment
yeah you don't bury your own child and
it was their only child
and of course mum was ill for three
years in the last year and a bit she was
in great pain
and uh it was it was tearing my
grandmother apart and she couldn't cope
and actually was quite difficult for
their relationship for a period because
it was so hurtful and then when you're
dealing with that pain
and my grandmother was also quite
she was quite tense around my mother and
my mother didn't really want my mother
loved her mother but the tension and
emotion coming from her
she she found it difficult to deal with
and she'd get a bit Snappy to yeah which
obviously you know that upset her more
when I was this young boy sort of in
between and I wrote this essay for my
assessed English O level
um it was all about
this how it was coming home
with the tension and knowing what my
mother was going through yeah
my my teacher said he couldn't mark it
because it was so raw yeah
because it's that mother-daughter
relationship as well which is I was
right in the middle of it yeah
um but it was you know they were both
wonderful lovely people well all three
of them my mother was special and uh
it's just one of these things but that's
why kinship character is so important
you don't have that with anyone else
yeah and uh I'm sure foster care is an
adoptee carers um
a brilliant and wonderful
um but uh
the the not allowing kinship carers to
do what they want to do
is a serious mistake